COKE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
ONE MEMBER IS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY OUR VICE CHAIR
SENATOR BATES. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR BATES CAN YOU HEAR US.
YES I CAN GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON AND IF YOU HAVE A
STAFF PERSON WITH YOU CAN YOU
PLEASE IDENTIFY THEM. YES I DO
I HAVE MY EXECUTIVE ASSISTANT
REYES TRACK AND WITH ME TODAY.
THANK YOU. SENATORS AS A
REMINDER PLEASE NOTE YOU CAN
USE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. AFTER EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE IT USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO AND MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT A NEW BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK. ON MUTE ONCE
YOU'RE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED.
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE
SEEN THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME. AND YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE- TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS HAVE ADMIT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT.
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED. ON OUR
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. IT'LL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT SEVEN SIX. EIGHT
NINE FOUR ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REPORT FOR TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE ZERO FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. S. IS ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE AND MUTED AND YOU
WILL BE READY. TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY DEVOID KEEP ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK AGAIN YOU MUST ON
MUTE. THE DEVICE ARE MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY ON THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND PRESENCE. I
WILL ALSO MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING A HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE.
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS.
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND
IT'S CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER.
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES. FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL. AND
PATIENT TO ALL. INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY WILL
VOTE TO ESTABLISH COMMITTEE
POLICIES AND THEN WILL HAVE ONE
BUILT TO BE HEARD ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. BEFORE WE GET TO THAT
THAT LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS CONSULTANTS. HERE THE
DALLAS HERE BATES. HERE BATES
HERE ALLEN. ALLEN HERE SUCH A
LETTER. BAKER THERE BAKER HERE
CORTESE. CORTESE HERE DOLLY.
DOLLY HERE MCGUIRE. SO SAN DODD
SENATOR. DOT DOT THANK YOU. NOW
BACK AS MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ HERE MEN. NEWMAN
NEWMAN HERE RUBIO. RUBIO HERE
SKINNER. SKINNER HERE NUMBER
NUMBER CARE WHITE HOUSE HERE I
COUNTY HERE WILL. WE HAVE A
QUORUM MADAM CHAIR. THE
CONSULTANT OF QUORUM BEEN A
STEP HINK YOU. OKAY FIRST WE
WILL HAND THE COMMITTEE POLICY
MEMBER THESE POP ARE KEY OVERS
LAST YEAR TO POLICY HAVE
DROPPED ONE DEAL WITH THE CA.
OF ANY- OMNIBUS BILL. AND THE
OTHER POLICY REGARDING THE
SETTING OF SPEED LIMITS- IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO THE
ADOPTION OF THESE POLICIES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE COMMITTEE
POLICIES ARE ADOPTED.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SORRY THAT'S RIGHT. NOW LET'S
GET ON TO THE BILL WILL MOVE ON
FORWARD TO THAT WELCOME SENATOR
DID ALSO YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL ON S. FIFTY ONE PLEASE.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND YOUR CA TA FOR THE TOP. AND
FOR THEIR EXPERT. THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT TO MY COME. NUMBER
THREE YOU ALL. SB FOR ONE
ADDRESS AND- URGENT CRISIS MY
DISTRICT WHILE ALSO PROVIDING A
MODEL FOR DOUBLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. THAT ALIGNS WITH
GOVERNOR NUISANCE EXECUTIVE
ACTIONS TO FOSTER HOUSING
INNOVATION ON EXCESS STATE LAND
AND RAPIDLY INCREASE HOUSING
OPTIONS. SB FIFTY ONE PROVIDES
A PATHWAY TO HOMEOWNERSHIP WELL
ALLOWING FOR THE SALE OF
CALTRANS PROPERTIES TO
QUALIFIED HOUSING RELATED
ENTITIES. SUCH AS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND NONPROFIT
HOUSING ENTITIES AT THE
CALTRANS ORIGINAL PURCHASE
PRICE. IN EXCHANGE FOR A
GUARANTEE A PROVIDING FIFTY
FIVE YEARS OF AFFORDABLE AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING. THE
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE OF THIS BILL
TO THE RULES ON HOW THESE
PROPERTIES ARE SOLD BY THE
STATE. IS THAT WE ESTABLISH THE
PURCHASE PRICE FOR H. E. R. H.
ARI'S AT THE ORIGINAL CALTRANS
CALTRANS PRICE IN EXCHANGE FOR
FIFTY FIVE YEARS OF
AFFORDABILITY. UNDER SB FIFTY
ONE THE HOMES WOULD BE SOLD BY
CALTRANS AS FOLLOWS. FIRST ALL
SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCES.
PRESENTLY OCCUPIED BY THEIR
FORMER OWNERS WILL BE OFFERED
TO THOSE OWNERS. AT THE FAIR
MARKET VALUE. SECOND ALL SINGLE
FAMILY RESIDENCES SHALL BE
OFFERED AT AN AFFORDABLE PRICE
TO THE PRESENT OCCUPANTS WHO
HAVE BEEN IN THE PROPERTY FOR
TWO OR MORE YEARS AND WHO ARE
LOW OR MODERATE INCOME. THIRD
IF A CURRENT LONG TERM TENANT
IN GOOD STANDING IS OVER THE
INCOME LIMITS AND HAS RESIDED
AT THE PROPERTY FOR FIVE YEARS
OR MORE. WE AMEND THE RIVER AND
A WATERFALL SO THAT THESE
TENANTS HAVE THE FIRST RIGHT TO
PURCHASE THEIR FOR. RENTAL AT
FAIR MARKET VALUE. AND THAT IS
THE PRICE REQUIRED BY CURRENT
LAW. THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY TO
PURCHASE THEN GOES TO THE HRB.
AT ORIGINAL ACQUISITION PRICE.
AS IS. BOB WITHOUT ADJUSTING
FOR INFLATION FOR THE PURPOSE
OF LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING WITH A FIFTY FIVE YEAR
COVENANT. SB FIFTY ONE ALLOWS
AN HRV THE BY THE PROPERTY AT
THE ORIGINAL PRICE IN EXCHANGE
FOR REMODELING THEM FIXING THEM
UP AND KEEPING THEM UP. OF
GRATED AND AFFORDABLE. THIS
BILL PROTECTS AGAINST
DISPLACEMENT. CURRENT TENANTS
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE A FIRST
RIGHT OF OCCUPANCY REGARDLESS
OF WHICH ENTITY PURCHASES THE
PROPERTY. COLLEAGUES SEVENTY
YEARS AGO THROUGH EMINENT
DOMAIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BEGAN DISPLACING FAMILIES AND
ALTER THE COMMUNITY OF EL
SERENO FOR FREEWAY EXPANSION.
CALTRANS BOUGHT PROPERTIES
WITHOUT REGARD FOR THE FAMILIES
IN THE QUARTER. DISRUPTED THE
ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
FABRIC OF THIS PREDOMINANTLY
LATINO COMMUNITY. AFFECTED JUST
A YEAR AGO IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THE LEGISLATURE DECLARED
THERE WOULD BE NO EXTENSION FOR
INTERSTATE SEVEN TEN. WITH OVER
pVACANT NEARLY HALF THE CALTRAIN
HOMES IN EL SERENO AND MANY
IMPORTANT CONDITIONS WE HAVE AN
URGENT OPPORTUNITY. TO REPAIR
AND IMPROVE THE HOUSING IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD AN INCREASE LONG
TORN TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
90% OF THE VACANT CALTRAIN
HOMES IN LOS ANGELES ARE IN
THIS COMMUNITY OF EL SERENO. OF
THE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
HOMES NEARLY HALF ARE VACANT.
NOT ONLY IS THIS CRITICAL FOR
THE COMMUNITY IT IS ALSO
FISCALLY PRUDENT RIGHT NOW
CALTRANS IS REQUIRED TO FIX THE
HOMES IN ORDER TO SELL THE
PROPERTIES AS MOST OF THESE
HOMES WOULD NOT QUALIFY FOR HAD
A BIT HABITABILITY STANDARDS.
CALTRANS IS ALSO INCURRING
SIGNIFICANT COSTS EVERYDAY TO
PREVENT THE HOMES FROM BEING
OCCUPIED. THESE HOMES IN THE
CURRENT CONDITIONS ARE
HAZARDOUS AND NOT SAFE FOR
LIVING IN WE WANT TO REPAIR
THESE HOMES MAKE THEM
RESPECTFUL DIGNIFIED. LIVING
SPACES WHILE EXPANDING LONG
TERM AFFORDABILITY. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO MOVE OWNERSHIP AWAY.
CALTRANS INTO THE HANDS OF
INDIVIDUAL OWNERS. SECURE LONG
TERM AFFORDABILITY WHILE
ENSURING CURRENT CURRENT
CALTRANS TENANTS ARE PROTECTED.
RESIDENTS RENTING APARTMENTS
AND HOMES IN THE SEVEN TEN
QUARTER DESERVE FAIR TREATMENT
AND STABLE HOUSING SB FIFTY ONE
WILL PROVIDE A LONG TERM
SOLUTION WILL BUILD WEALTH IN
EQUITY IN THE COMMUNITY THROUGH
HOMEOWNERSHIP. FOCUSED ON THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF EXPANDING AND
PRESERVING AFFORDABILITY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE A WITNESS AMY ANDERSON
CHIEF HOUSING OFFICER OF THE
CITY HOMELESSNESS INITIATIVES
WITH THE OFFICE OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR GARCETTI THANK YOU
SENATOR GRASSO- WE'LL BEGIN
WITH YOUR LEAD WITNESS. AND AS
YOU MENTIONED IN THE ANDERSON
WITH LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI'S OFFICE. WE HAVE YOU
ON THE LINE.
I THINK IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT THERE GETTING HER
ON THE LINE NOW.
YEAH YEAH.
OKAY. OKAY. WE'LL JUST WAIT ONE
MORE MINUTE IF NOT WE'LL GO TO
THE GALLERY FOR ANY WITNESSES
AND WE'LL COME BACK TO HER IF
SHE'S NOT ON THE LINE. DO YOU
HAVE SOMEBODY- QUEUING UP TO
SOME OF. OKAY SINCE WE DON'T
HAVE YOUR LEAD WITNESS AT THIS
MOMENT CENTER THAT ALSO WE'RE
GONNA GO TO- WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB. FIFTY ONE.
OKAY THERE ARE NONE SO WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO BACK TO
THE CO HOST LINE WITH AMY
ANDERSON WITH LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI'S OFFICE. OKAY.
THE CONFERENCE OKAY SO SHE'S
NOT AVAILABLE AT THIS MOMENT WE
MIGHT HAVE SOME TECHNICAL
ISSUES THERE BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED IN ORDER TO FIND.
OKAY WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ANY
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD BEGIN PLEASE
PROMPTING ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FIFTY ONE WE WILL BEGIN.
SURE YOU WISH. TO ANY OTHER
THING ANYONE HERE. YES I CAN
HEAR YOU. OUR HI. ILLYRIAN THE
MICROPHONE AFTER IT IS ZANY
AYATOLLAH I HAVING OF OKAY WE
DO WANNA MAKE AND WORK FOR HERE
THAT LEAD WITH AMY WITH PLUS
AND- MAYOR ERIC ARE OFFICE
BEGIN WE YOU IF YOU LIKE TO
BEGIN AMY AND THEN WE'LL GO
BACK TO OUR WITNESS FOR A
SUPPORT. GREAT I AM. ABOUT THAT
DIFFICULTY AND THANK YOU FOR US.
THE FACT- YOU KNOW I WANT TO
JOIN THE- CALL IN ORDER. TO
STRONG FOR A BI FIFTEEN- YOU
KNOW THAT HEALTHY PARTNER. HAS
THE TERM THAT 48% OF WILLING
HEALTH. IN L. A. COUNTY. ARE
NOW SPENDING MORE 50% OF THEIR
INCOME HOUSING. THE PARTNERSHIP
THAT. N. L. A. COUNTY MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED DOWN AFFORDABLE.
SUFFICIENTLY GREENSPAN.
CRITICALLY NOT A SIMPLE
SOLUTION FOR EXPANDING THE
FINANCE OF AFFORDABLE HOMES-
BECAUSE BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOMES HAS COME. AND EXPENSIVE
ENDEAVOR. REALLY ONE OF THE
MOST EFFECTIVE. BUT THE STATE
CAN MAKE IN CREATING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RESOURCES CONTRIBUTED
ON LAND AND PROPERTY OUT THAT.
AT THE MINIMUM COST. AND THIS
BY A. FIFTY ONE- REALLY WHAT
THE TO WITH TO THE HOUSING OF
CRISIS THAT IT MAY CONFIRM THE
NEED. TO DEDICATE CAL- HOW AND
OTHER. IN THE L. THREE
COMMUNITY. BEING LONG TERM
HOUSING RESOURCES. I NEED TO
MAKE SOME OF FOR THAT PER
PURPOSE AND QUICKLY AS- AND TO
MAKE THEM UP. AT VERY LOW COST
SO THAT ANY REAL ABILITY OR OR
NO NEW BUILDING THAT- ENABLE TO
GO ON ON THE SITE. IS MORE
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE. I DON'T
REALLY TO PHILIP K. TRANSITION
OF THE WAY CAL. FOR CALTRANS
FOR THERE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
INTO THE HANDS OF ORGANIZATIONS
WITH THE CAPACITY IN THE
EXPERIENCE OF BOTH BILLS. AND
OPERATE- BE. HOME AND
AFFORDABLE RESOURCES LONG TERM-
REALLY I. COME RIGHT BY SAYING
YOU'RE GIVES SAME A GREAT. TO
DONE THAT I CAN READ TO THE
CRISIS. AFFECTED LEE AND HIS
ACCOUNTABLE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AMY. NOW WE WILL WE HAD
ALREADY ARE WE IN ROOM TWELVE
THEIR WERE NONE SO WE WILL MOVE
ON TO ANY WITNESS WAITING TO
VIA THE TO ORVIS MODERATE IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE ANY INDIVIDUAL
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY ONE WE WILL BEGIN.
ABSOLUTELY THEY DETERMINE IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK
YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. SO FAR WE HAVE ONE IN
Q. OKAY GREAT THEY MAY PROCEED.
JUST A BRIEF MOMENT WE'RE
GETTING THE LINE NUMBER THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE A COMMON FROM LINE
NUMBER TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS THIS IS NOT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. OKAY WE
WILL OPEN UP I DO READ THE
WRONG NUMBER OKAY. BUT THAT'S
FINE WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
COME BACK TO OPPOSITION IN A
MOMENT MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY-
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTY ONE. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU- IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES- AND ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE ANY. OF WITNESSES THAT
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO SB. FIFTY
ONE. THE GENTLEMAN IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY
FIRST TO GO TO LINE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN. ALRIGHT I
NINETY MINUTES I'D LOVE LEVINE
MY NAME IS ANGELA FLORES I AM A
LONG TIME TENANTS- MY FAMILY'S
BEEN LIVING IN OUR HOUSE IN
SOUTH PASADENA FOR THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S- INFURIATING
IT'S FRUSTRATING- AFTER-
GROWING UP. WITH SO MANY
TENANTS WHO HAD TO FIGHT FOR
THEIR HOME A LOT OF THOSE
TENANTS ARE OLDER AND HAVING TO
FEED THEIR GRIEVANCES HAVING TO
SEE THERE ARE PEOPLE PASSING
AWAY UNFORTUNATELY AND TO NOT
BE CONSULTED BY MISTER MIRACLE
IS VERY INFURIATING AND
RIDICULOUS. SO I THINK IT'S-
IT'S RIDICULOUS ALSO THAT THERE
IS- AND A GROUP CALLED THE
INCIDENT ALL COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST TENANTS LED AND RESIDENT
LANDON THAT SHE HASN'T TALKED
TO AND THAT- THAT GROUP IS
WILLING TO TAKE THE PROPERTIES
AND TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
POLITICAL PROPERTIES AND REACH
READ- RESTORED THEN SO THAT IS
BY THE TENANTS AND A LOT OF THE
INFORMATION THAT SHE SAID WAS
THE FIRST TIME EVER HEARING
ABOUT IT. SO IT'S VERY INFERIOR
AND VOEPEL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
IN Q. IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIFTY
ONE. YES NEXT WE GO TO LINE A-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. THANK
YOU- I AMERICA CALTRANS TENET
ALSO A MEMBER OF OUR GROUP IN
ASSOCIATION WITH IT AND- WHEN
SENATOR DORADO STROKE IT ALL
SOUNDED VERY REASONABLE AND- WE
WOULD BE IN AGREEMENT WITH
THOSE THINGS BUT THOSE THINGS
ARE ALREADY- ALREADY INCLUDED
IN EXISTING LEGISLATION BUT THE
ADDITIONAL CHANGES IN SB FIFTY
ONE. HE WAS MORE LIKE AN
ATTEMPT TO MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER
OF PARCELS AVAILABLE TO HOUSING
RELATED ENTITIES- AND COULD
POSSIBLY TAKE AWAY THE RIGHTS
OF TENANTS WHO ARE ALREADY
THERE- HI IT WOULD BE CONTINUE
TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST THE
ALTERING OF COMMUNITY AND ALLOW
CALTRANS TO CONTINUE WITH
THEIR- UNFAIR AND UNFOUNDED
MUSICIANS- IT ALSO WILL-
ARBITRARILY ELIMINATES THE
RIGHT TO TENANTS TO FORM CO OPS
TO PURCHASE CALTRANS HOMES. AND
ONLY IN EL SERENO- CURRENTLY
DORADO HAS DEBATED NUMEROUS
ATTEMPTS FOR COMMUNITY DIALOGUE
AN IMPORT- IT SEEMS TO SERVE
SPECIAL THE CHANGES IN SB FIFTY
ONE. SEEM TO SERVE SPECIAL
INTERESTS GROUPS RATHER THAN
THE TENANTS- IT GIVES PRIORITY
TO RENTAL AND PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT OVER THE RIGHTS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND THE RIGHT OF
THE COMMUNITY TO DETERMINE ITS
OWN FUTURE- AND IT DOES NOTHING
TO CHALLENGE CALTRANS SOME WORK
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
HOLD THE WORST PLAN OF THIS BY
DE LEON. ANYWAY I WANTED TO
SHOW ALL THAT IN SO ON IT FACE
SOUNDS GREAT- WHAT SENATOR DRAW
WAS SOME GOOD. BUT A LOT OF
VERY THERE- THAT- THINK IT
MIGHT CALL- THANK FOR YOUR
COMMENT WILL TAKE THE NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. MEXICO TO LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. K.
LOOKING TO MOVE ONTO LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU GO RIGHT AHEAD. MY NAME IS
REBECCA. FORMER TENANT HI IN
GOOD STANDING- BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER PROBLEM THAT CALTRANS-
UNILATERALLY HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO DECLARE WAS CONGRESS
STANDING SIDE AND THEY'RE NOT
TO BE VERY VINDICTIVE AND- THE
LAWSUIT BILL THERE'S NOT
ADDRESS- CALTRANS- I RAN A COOL
BLUE OVER TENANTS- THE ONLY
THING THAT I'D LIKE TO
REITERATE THE WHOLE THING ABOUT
DISCRIMINATION. THIS IS THIS
BILL ONLY APPLIES TO ANSWERING
A DOES NOT APPLY TO SOUTH
PASADENA ARE PASADENA AND
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST A HUNDRED
TEN AND- COMMITTEE IT TAKES
AWAY- THINGS THAT BENEFITS AND
RIGHTS THAT ARE WITHIN THE BILL
LIKE- RIGHT TOOL COOPER WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN TO THE MULTI
FAMILY UNITS. HOWEVER THE
COMBINED- WITHIN THE REPORTING
BILLION UP. GIVES THE RIGHT
FORM A CORE WHILE- TO WAIT
RIGHT TO. AND SO FOR THAT ALL
THE THAT ALREADY BEEN STATE
NINE I. A HARD TO BE A COLD- SB
FIFTY ONE AND I. QUITE A FEW
PEOPLE. FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
FOLLOWING IN THE L. AREA. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS WE'LL GO
THE NEXT ROOM IT- THE PERSON IS
A CALLING IN THE OF ABOUT ONE
MINUTE THANK YOU. THANKS TO GO
TO LINE. PLEASE CALL AT.
EVERYONE ON MY FEET AND THAT
I'M A LOT RED OF THE CITY NO.
I'M CALLING IN- KIDS THAT YOU
KNOW THAT I AM NOT TO THE
DOCTOR BILL AS B. ONE- I AM OF
THE GROUP AS WE CAME WE BUILD
OUR COMMUNITY HERE IN A AT NO.
WE'VE BEEN TRYING GET IN TOUCH
WITH HER FOR ABOUT TWO MONTHS
NOW SINCE WE TOOK A DIRECT
OPTION- ON THE COURT OR ON THE
DIFFERENT SEVENTEEN CORRIDOR I
NEED TO TALK TO PUT OUT A
STATEMENT AGAINST- MY GROUP TO
RECLAIM HERS. AND HAD NOT MADE
HERSELF AVAILABLE TO SPEAK WITH
US WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO HAVE
DIALOGUE AS WE'VE BEEN- MADE
AWARE OF. HER SHE BILL THROUGH.
AND IF. MAKING IT VERY DIRECT.
ALSO READ AND I FEEL THAT IT
VERY BY- I FEEL THE- AND SHE'S
DIRECTLY. I MY CAN. FIVE NINE
ZERO TWO TWO- AS THE PREVIOUS-
CALL MENTION- DOES NOT APPLY
STOP HAPPENED OR PAY. FOR ALL
ON THE CORRIDOR. INTO A IT'S A
LOT- ENVIRONMENTAL. ON HER
BEHALF. AN HER CONSTITUENTS I
WOULD LIKE- YOU GUYS SHE WAS.
REALLY TAKE THIS INTO MIND AND
KNOW THAT. AND WE THE RESIDENTS
ABOUT THREE NOTE DO NOT AGREE
WITH THIS BILL AND I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK TENER DORADO IF YOU ARE
IN THE SENATE FLOOR TODAY AND
LISTENING. THAT YOU GAVE YOUR
WORD AND- SEND A LETTER TO
EITHER GIVE US A CALL TO GET
BEEN TRYING TO REACH YOU FOR
TWO MONTHS. THAT'S ALL THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU FOR COMING NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT TO THE TO
LINE FORTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT. HI LINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO OPEN.
RIGHT I HAD YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
YEAH THIS. THAT I AM IS ABOUT
TURN TENANTS AND I AM OPPOSED
TO THE S. B. FIFTY ONE I THINK
IT'S DISCRIMINATORY- AND THEY
NEED TO GO AWAY NOW. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. THANKS FOR THE
TO LINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HI THIS IS- TIM ANDERSON
I'M A TENANT IN THE SEVEN TEN
QUARTER AND I OPPOSE THAT'S THE
FIFTY ONE. I ANY UNDERSTANDING
DORSEN OF THE OF THE BILL TO
SPEND BUT- I THINK IT. YOU KNOW
THIS BILL RELIES ON MOST PEOPLE
ACTUALLY NOT UNDERSTANDING WHAT
IS ALREADY ESTABLISHED IN
REGARDS THAT YOU. BY COMPARISON
ITSELF ARBITRARILY LIMITS THE
RIGHTS OF TENANTS TO FORM
COOPERATIVES IN ORDER TO BECOME
HOMEOWNERS IN LINE WITH THE-
LEGISLATION. IT DOESN'T ONLY IN
EL SERENO WHICH IS BLATANTLY
DISCRIMINATORY IN FACT
EVERYTHING THAT SB FIFTY ONE
CLAIMS TO ACHIEVE CAN ALREADY
BE DONE UNDER EXISTING
LEGISLATION. WHICH APPLIES TO
THE ENTIRE CORRIDOR INCLUDING
SOUTH PASADENA IN PASADENA. I
URGE THE SENATE TO OPPOSE THIS
DEEPLY FLAWED BILL AND- I WOULD
CHALLENGE THE SENATOR TO
EXPLAIN WHY DIDN'T THE EXPANDED
TO THE ENTIRE COURT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT AND
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
ME THE REMAINING NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. ARE THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU MODERATOR- IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE UP. ONCE ARE WE DONE
THAT SINCE WE'VE GONE THROUGH
OF THE TELECONFERENCE THEN
WE'LL GO BACK TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FIFTY ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. WISH TO TESTIFY. OKAY I
SEEN AN THANK YOU SO WILL BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- WELL FIRST OF ALL I JUST
WANT TO START BY COMMENDING
SENATOR AND- ALSO FOR THIS
MEASURE I KNOW THAT SHE'S BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD. ALL THE
LAST YEAR ON THIS BILL ON AND I
THINK DUE TO COVER THERE ARE
SOME CHALLENGES THERE BY THE
TIME I WANT TO TAKE THIS MOMENT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OF THE
CALLS. AND LETTERS OF MY
DISTRICT HAS RECEIVED IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL- SO I
KNOW THERE'S SOME EDUCATION TO
BE DONE IN THAT RESPECT IN SOME
MEETINGS THAT PERHAPS NEED TO
HAPPEN JUST TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
ARE INFORMED AND- ITEMS
CLARIFIED BUT I DID HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING. ALL LAST
YEAR WITH SENATOR DRAWS ON. YOU
DON'T REALLY GET POLICIES THAT
CREATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING HELP
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
IN PARTICULAR HELP. LOW INCOME
FAMILIES STAY IN THEIR HOMES SO
I KNOW THAT. THIS BILL WAS
MEANT TO CREATE OPPORTUNITY SO
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BY TWO CLEARLY THERE'S
SOME AGAIN EDUCATION TO BE DONE
AND- AND SOME MEETINGS TO BE
HAD AND SO I TRUST MY
COLLEAGUES WITH MY COLLEAGUE-
WILL DO THAT SO WITH THAT I
WILL. URGE AND I BOTH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SENATOR WITH
HOUSEKEEPING- BANKING MANAGER
I'M ON THE PAGE FIVE UNDER
BULLET NUMBER FOUR AND ROLLS
OVER THE PAGE SIX I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY UNDERSTAND.
MADAM CHAIR THAT THERE IS A
PRIORITY AND TO THE RIVER TO
THE ACT THAT THAT ALLOWS THESE
HOUSES TO BE OFFERED. BACK TO
THE FORMER OWNERS AT THE PRICE
THAT WAS PAID AND ACCORDING TO
OUR ANALYSIS JUST MAY BE IN THE
FIFTIES IN THE SIXTIES SO I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT EL SERENO BUT
I KNOW IN. IN THE BAY AREA YOU
TALKED AND THIRTY FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR HOUSES
COULD BE CHEAPER TO BUY A HOUSE
IN THIS AREA IF THAT WAS
ACTUALLY ACQUIRED IN THE
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES. IT WAS
THE BY A CAR BOMB. AND AN L.
CALTRANS HAS BEEN HANGING ONTO
THESE FOR EVER SO I THINK I
UNDERSTAND. WERE YOU UNDER THE
RIVER. BERTIE ACT. YOU IF
THERE'S ONE TO SAY RIGHT OF
FORMER TEN ARE NUMBER SIX OF
THE FORMER OWNER OR SOMEBODY
BEEN THERE FOR. YEARS WANTS TO.
PURCHASED THE PROPERTY DAY GET
FIRST DIBS. I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS THAT NOW THE BILL ALSO LIFTS
THE INCOME- THRESHOLDS FOR ANY
OF THESE ENTITIES PEOPLE THAT
FORMALLY. ENDED IN. MY QUESTION
IS THAT. IF A FORMER TENANT OR
SOMEBODY OWNER OR WHAT IDIOT
CATEGORY CENTER BERTIE SEX
THEY'RE NOT UNDER ANY
OBLIGATION TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
THIS PROPERTY- HAVE A FIFTY
FIVE YEAR COVENANTED REMAINS
REPORTER AFFORDABLE IT'S ONLY
IF. IT GOES TO A HOUSING
RELATED ENTITY THAT WOULD BY
THAT THE RESTRICTIONS WITH
FALLEN THE CORRECT. YOU HAVE A
HOUSING RELATED ENTITY AND
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE WANT RESPONSIBLE ENTITIES
AND SENATOR DIRECTLY WHEN IT-
SO MENTION THAT THAT'S OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MENTION THIS
IN YOUR CLOTHES OKAY I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
OTHER- OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM. OKAY SENATOR
ALAN AND THEN WILL ALLOW YOU TO
ADDRESS THAT ARE CLOSE. BY WE
JUST I ASSUME THAT THE CENTER
IS GOING TO RESPOND TO NUMBER
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED
ON THE PHONE CALLS I MEAN. THIS
WAS. NO I CAN SET CALENDAR-
CANDIDATE I THINK AS OF. TWELVE
HOURS AGO AND THERE'S NO
REGINALD POSITION IN OUR IN
OUR- BRIEFINGS BUT OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A SERIES OF CONCERNS
OUT THERE THAT- I CERTAINLY
WASN'T AWARE OF AND I'M I'M
HOPEFUL THAT- THE CENTER AND
OTHERS WILL CAST LIGHT ON. ON
ON WHAT HAS BEEN ALLEGED AND
WHAT THE PLAN IS MOVING FORWARD.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN AND YES THIS WAS ON
CONSENT AND WAS REMOVED-
BECAUSE OF THE OPPOSITIONAL
VERY LAST MINUTE BUT I WILL A
LOT IF THERE ARE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS AND I WILL PASS IT ON
TO SENATOR DRAWS A TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN A
COLLEAGUES- I'VE SPENT. ME AND
MY STAFF IS SPENT HUNDREDS OF
HOURS. MEETING WITH
ORGANIZATIONS. MEETING WITH
GROUPS MEETING WITH INFORMAL
GROUPS. NOT FORMALLY
ESTABLISHED ORGANIZATIONS. OF
WE HAVE DONE SURVEYS DOOR TO
DOOR. I HAVE CALLED ONE BY ONE.
MANY OF THE RESIDENTS IN THAT
AREA TO GET A COMPLETE PICTURE.
THIS BILL SB FIFTY ONE IS THE
RESULT OF THAT. NOW THIS IS B.
FIFTY ONE- SATISFY EVERY SINGLE
PERSON OR GROUP NO IT DOES NOT
BECAUSE THERE ARE LAYERS OF
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED AS
A RESULT OF DECADES SIXTY YEARS
OF BUYING THESE PROPERTIES
SIXTY YEARS OF WORK CALTRANS
WAS NOT THE KIND OF LANDLORD
THAT ANYBODY WOULD WANT BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT THEIR BUSINESS SO
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO. AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE AS SOON AS WE
HAVE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS MOVE
THIS PROPERTY SO THAT THOSE WHO
ARE IN A POSITION WANT TO AND
ARE TENANTS CAN BUY THESE HOMES
AND THOSE WHO CAN'T CAN STAY IN
THERE AS LONG AS IT'S
AFFORDABLE THERE IT'S THEY'RE
PROTECTED AS TENANTS TO STAY
THERE IF THEY WANT TO CONTINUE
TO RENT. AND THEN THOSE
REMAINING PROPERTIES WILL BE
TAKEN BY HOUSING RELATED ENTITY
TO BUILD INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- THE KIND OF ALL
TOGETHER BUILDING EQUITY
BUILDING WEALTH- ALLOWING FOR
AFFORDABILITY LONG TERM
STABILITY THAT'S WHAT ELSE I
DON'T KNOW DESERVES AND INSTEAD
OF BEING DISCRIMINATORY IT'S
GETTING THE FOCUS AND THE- THE
FOCUS THAT IT DESERVES THE
ATTENTION THAT IT DESERVES TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE REAL PLAN SO- COLLEAGUES
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
GRASSO AND THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE ALL THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO CALLED IN AS WELL I
DO HAVE A MOTION. ON SB FIFTY
ONE. OKAY BY SENATOR WHAT
KASKY. OF WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE MISTER
CONSULTANT. BUT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE SECOND DAHLE. HI DOLLARS HI
SENATOR BATES. AYE BATES AYE
CENTER ALAN HI ALAN HI SARAJ A
LETTER SENATOR BECKER ART BAKER
HI CENTER CORTESE HI CORTESE HI
SENATOR DOLLY. DOLLY HI SENATOR
DODD ALL RIGHT DODD HI SENATE
MCGUIRE. SENATOR MELENDEZ HI
MELENDEZ HI CENTER MEN BY MEN
HI SENATOR NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN HI SENATOR RUBIO HI
RUBIO HI CENTER SKINNER HI
SKINNER HI CENTER NUMBER ACT.
NUMBER HI CENTER WHITE HOUSE
GIG HI KELSEY HI SENATOR WILK
HI WILK HI. FIFTY FIFTEEN AYE
VOTES AND- TWO MEMBERS HAVE NOT
VOTED YET OKAY THANK YOU WILL
ACTUALLY PUT THIS ON CALL
BECAUSE THEY DO KNOW SENATOR
MCGUIRE WOULD LIKE TO COME BACK
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
RETURNING SOON SO THANK YOU
MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT- ROLE OPEN
ON CALL. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY
OKAY THIS IS A REMOTE. YES OKAY.
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR I'VE
FOUGHT ON. NINETY THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE TELLING. BUT I. MAYBE
THERE ARE SOME. OKAY OKAY
MISTER CLINTON LET'S THE ROLE%
AGAIN PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. SENATE MCGUIRE. OKAY
FIFTY NINE ZERO NOTES THANK YOU
THAT BILL HAS FIFTEEN EYES-
THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS OF THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU TO ALL INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US IN ONE
INCLUDED TESTIMONY MONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. WE'RE IN OUR
TURNED. AFTER.